bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission économique où on adore démonter
les fausses bonnes idées
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine allant des sujets préférés
d'olivier de la marche la dette bonjour
olivier bourges où m faut-il effacer la
dette détenue par la bce c'est la
question à laquelle on va tenter de
répondre cette semaine dans cette
émission pour en parler nous sommes en
liaison avec nicolas dufresne directeur
de l'institut rousseau bonjour monsieur
dufresne merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
bonjour à vous merci de votre invitation
pour parler de ce sujet important merci
l'année dernière une centaine
d'économistes de 13 pays européens
appelaient un effacement des dettes des
états détenus par la banque centrale
européenne un effacement en échange
d'une promesse de la part des états
membres investir cette somme dans la
reconstruction sociale et écologique une
demande louable mais dans les faits est
ce possible éléments de réponse avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine sas
[Musique]
avant de savoir s'il est souhaitable lui
d'effacer la dette détenue par la banque
centrale européenne qui représente 25%
des dettes des pays de lieux et dépasse
les 4 mille milliards d'euros il
convient déjà de se demander est ce que
c'est réellement faisable juridiquement
on entend souvent parler de l'article
123 du traité de lisbonne qui
empêcherait une annulation car il
interdit le financement des états par la
banque centrale sauf que la politique
monétaire actuelle qu'on tourne au déjà
cet article la bce rachetant massivement
les titres de dette des états membres
aux investisseurs privés pour ainsi
émettre de la monnaie et contrer les
crises comme celle du co vide ou celle
de 2008 la dette ne coûte rien aux états
les taux étant à 0 cela peut déjà être
considéré comme un financement des pays
par la bce est une violation du traité
en fait c'est presque déjà comme si
cette dette n'existait tout simplement
pas puisqu'elle ne coûte rien aux états
biya par ailleurs des précédents dans
l'histoire un défaut de paiement de la
france au xviiie siècle
allègement de la dette allemande à trois
reprises en 1931 1953 et 1990 mais le
plus emblématique est le cas de
l'argentine outils au début des années
2000 a réussi à faire a livré sa dette
pour contrer une forte inflation les
détracteurs argueront que 20 ans plus
tard l'argentine est toujours empêtrée
dans ses problèmes de dette et que
l'annulation passé n'a pas servi à grand
chose
nicolas dufresne pour qu'on comprenne à
annuler la dette détenue par la bce est
ce que c'est vraiment juridiquement
faisable
oui alors ce n'est pas illégal puisque
ce n'est pas une opération de
financement monétaire c'est une
opération
d'abandon de créances comme en fout
finalement les banques privées tous les
jours et on voit pas ce qui empêcherait
la bce de le faire puisqu'il n'y a
absolument aucun traité qui interdit à
une banque publique fut telle une banque
centrale d'abandonner les créances
qu'elle détient il faut bien avoir en
tête que le financement monétaire a déjà
eu lieu alors ce n'est pas illégal mais
bien sûr ce n'est pas non plus prévu
expressément par les traiter c'est à
dire qu'on est dans une zone grise
puisque on se retrouve dans une
situation inédite
puisque le traité de maastricht dès
l'origine de la fondation de l'euro
voulait précisément éviter une situation
dans laquelle la banque centrale se
retrouveraient
détentrice de plusieurs
milliers de milliards d'euros de dette
des états membres de la zone euro donc
c'est une situation que les rédacteurs
du traité n'avait évidemment pas
anticipé qui n'aurait pas dû se produire
et qui montre que finalement déjà la
pratique et au delà du droit et donc
l'annulation ne serait pas plus
illégales comme il a été dit dans votre
sujet que tout ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
maintenant en termes de politique
monétaire comme nous l'appelons
conventionnelle c'est à dire en dehors
des conventions rien vous êtes d'accord
avec pour moi c'est pas un problème
juridique
le
l'europe et les pays européens ça soit
sur les traités depuis depuis le depuis
2008 on a faim on n'a même pas besoin de
remonter on n'essaie pas une histoire de
kovy de quoi que ce soit
c'est depuis 2008 on a fait fi de tous
les deux tout les de tous les traités
donc c'est pas un problème juridique
c'est un problème économique mais pas du
tout un problème juridique après vous
savez leleu qui fait la loi c'est c'est
la commission européenne s'est scellé
les pays donc s'ils ont besoin de la
changer il à changement et croyez moi ça
fait suffisamment longtemps que la bce
fait des choses qui n'était absolument
pas prévu au départ pour que ça ne
change rien mais le problème il n'est
pas je vous dis il n'est pas au niveau
juridique au niveau juridique c'est pas
un souci c'est au niveau économique ça
pose un problème mais
certains pensent qu'il n'y a aucune
conséquence à ça en revanche il y en a
il y en a des lourds donc c'est pour ça
que c'est une très mauvaise idée olivier
c'est presque déjà comme si cette dette
n'existait tout simplement pas c'est ce
qu'on a entendu dans le tiroir cash est
ce que c'est aussi simple que ça non
c'est ridicule ça se sait c'est pas
parce que c'est pas parce que c'est là
la bce qui détient les titres
des états que cette bête n'existe pas
cette dette elle a été créée elle a été
émise par les états et elle a été
rachetée par pas d'ailleurs que par les
états puisque la bce a racheté aussi des
dettes privées donc d'entreprises
privées donc ces dettes ont été émises
ces dettes ont une réalité c'est pas des
dons des bêtes il ya une petite
différence de d'écriture mais qui a son
importance c'est pas la même chose donc
une dette normalement cette année est
remboursée et est donc
dire qu'elle n'existe pas c'est cette
c'est une bêtise
la deuxième chose qu'il faut la deuxième
chose qu'il faut dire là dessus c'est
que à propos de du consensus des états
vous n'aurez jamais le consensus de
l'allemagne d'accord l'allemagne n'est
pas du tout dans cette dans cet
esprit-là l'allemagne je vous rappelle à
une dette qui est autour de 65% 68% donc
très très loin de tous les autres et
donc elle ne verrait pas de je suppose
d'un bon oeil qu'on annule les dettes
dans les pays qui n'ont absolument rien
fait pour la maîtriser comme la france
comme l'italie comme l'espagne et
compagnie donc je pense que le jour vous
aurez la corde l'allemagne les poules
auront des dents mais voilà dufresne
vouliez réagir à ce qu'a dit olivier oui
alors sur deux points déjà sur le
constat que c'est pas parce que la bce
détient une dette que elle n'existe pas
je suis tout à fait d'accord et c'est
d'ailleurs bien pour ça qu'on propose
une annulation de dd dette détenue par
par la bce parce que c'est une erreur
que font beaucoup y compris de
d'économistes il considère que parce que
la bce reverse une partie des intérêts
qu'elle perçoit sur ces dettes publiques
aux états c'est comme si la dette
n'existait pas parce que les états font
rouler leurs dettes c'est complètement
faux les états doivent rembourser
l'argent qu'ils ont empruntés à la bce
et lorsqu ils remboursent cet argent cet
argent est détruit c'est à dire
exactement de la façon dont ça se passe
dans le système bancaire traditionnel
quand vous rembourser un prêt qui a été
créateur de monnaie la créance est
détruite et la monnaie avec et donc ça
le remboursement de cette dette pèse sur
le chalet dire sur les finances
publiques et sur la capacité des
finances publiques à financer d'autres
dépenses notamment pour la transition
écologique maintenant sur le consensus
nécessaire au niveau européen ou en tout
cas de la large majorité
oui je lui ai évidemment qu'il y aura
des difficultés et mais toutes ces
difficultés sont propres finalement au
fonctionnement de l'union économique et
monétaire elles ne sont pas nouvelles il
ya les pics frugaux les pays qui ont
plus intérêt à
avoir des politiques monétaires
progressiste et finalement on retrouve
ce même clivage aussi sur ces questions
là même si on a eu nous avez rappelé la
tribune des 150 économistes l'année
dernière qui se sont prononcés en faveur
de cette solution il y avait plusieurs
allemands des néerlandais des belges des
danois
donc d'aider des personnes des pays du
nord la question c'est est ce qu'on
s'est toujours au
nein allemand moi je crois que non il y
à un moment il faut qu'on comprenne
aussi que les allemands bénéficient
très fortement de l'existence de l'euro
puisque si il n'y avait pas l'euro le la
valeur du marque étant donné les
excédents commerciaux
extrêmement important de l'allemagne la
valeur du marque sans l'euro
s'envolerait ce qui plomberait
immédiatement sous ses excédents
commerciaux et donc il ya là des enjeux
de négociations avec l'allemagne qu'il
faut avoir en tête et d'ailleurs on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui sur les fameuses
règles de maastricht donc les 3% de
déficit public et les 60% de dette
aujourd'hui l'allemagne est prête à des
compromis on nous avait dit que jamais
l'allemagne ne pourrait revenir sur ces
critères de maastricht aujourd'hui les
allemands s'y montre prêt et il il ya
des velléités de réformer ces critères
là dans les mois ou les années à venir
même si bien sûr ce n'est pas encore
fait voulez vous allez répondre ce sera
juste après la pub
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine
faute il effacer la dette détenue par la
bce est pour en parler nous sommes avec
nicolas dufresne directeur de l'institut
rousseau olivier une réaction est ce que
disait monsieur dufresne juste avant la
paix notamment sur l'allemagne qui était
qui était prête à des compromis selon
lui je voyais faire non de la tête non
parce que ils sont prêts à céder sur sur
certaines choses qui ne ne trouve pas
importante en revanche
je suis absolument désolé de vous dire
que c'est quand même l'allemagne qui
dirige et la bce et de l'union
européenne c'est pas parce que je macron
là est allé faire un le bo à la tribune
de l'europe mais qu'il a pris la
présidence que il dirige quoi que ce
soit on dirige quand on a les sous et ce
n'est pas le cas de la france donc ça
c'est une première chose et puis je vous
rappelle qu'en plus sur toutes décisions
européennes et il faut le il faut
l'unanimité donc on est loin de l'avoir
et donc
mais c'est plutôt une bonne chose parce
que
moi je considère que les allemands
savent compter les autres beaucoup moins
10 nicolas des frênes sur le deutschmark
sur le deutschmark 9,1
l'allemagne n'a pas n'a pas commencé à
exister en 2000 avec l'euro elle a
toujours vécu avec un dodge marque qui
était beaucoup plus fort que toutes les
autres monnaies et que je sache ils
n'ont pas péricliter donc cette cette
idée que il faut absolument avoir une
monnaie extrêmement faible pour les
allemands pour continuer à exporter est
une est une bêtise et qui est d'une
bêtise qui est contrarié par les faits
vous avez des pays qui ont une monnaie
extrêmement forte et qui continue à
exporter et qui continuent à avoir une
une économie qui se porte beaucoup mieux
que que la france ou que ou que d'autres
que d'autres pays donc c'est un faux
problème et
je vous dis je doute que les allemands
et les économistes allemands et les
dirigeants allemands qui savent compter
contrairement à notre ministère de
l'économie qui savent parfaitement
compte et donc je doute que ils soient
sur la même longueur d'onde sur le fait
d' effacer des dettes
leleu tipp-ex n'étant pas une solution
viable l'économiste évoqué olivier le
ministère de l'économie on l'a dit a pas
vraiment aujourd'hui de volonté
politique d'aller sur le terrain de
l'annulation de la lettre que ce soit
christine lagarde la présidente de la
bce pour qui l'annulation de la dette
est inenvisageable ou encore en france
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
qui a justifié quand on emprunte de
l'argent si vous voulez que les gens
continuent de vous en prêter il faut
leur donner une seule garantie que vous
les rembourserez pour une fois vous êtes
d'accord avec eux alors pour une fois je
suis je suis d'accord avec eux mais
c'est le sait aussi je voulais rebondir
sur ce que avait dit
monsieur dufresne
à propos de du remboursement par les
états de la dette jamais un état ne
rembourse jamais d'accord ils roulent
ils roulent les emprunts mais ils ne
remboursent n'empêche pas qu'ils
remboursent non remboursés parce qu'il
aimait une dette pour pour rembourser
celle qui arrive à échéance alors je
suis désolé mais ça fait ça fait quand
même beaucoup d'années qu'on fait ça
donc ya pas de remboursement en fait il
ya simplement une
position qui est roulé et quand elles
roulent et elle ne se rembourse pas
c'est à dire qu'elle ne me répond pas on
aimait un emprunt qui sert à en effet
éteindre le le le la dette précédente et
qui nous fait repartir sur 10 ans mais
ça ne s'appelle pas un remboursement de
ben ali nicolas s'était alors non sur ce
point là je suis vraiment pas d'accord
je pense à un point qui est mal compris
en fait bien sûr on rembourse une dette
et on réemprunte et on qu'on fait rouler
la dette sauf que vous ne la fait pas
aux mêmes conditions par exemple
aujourd'hui on voit des taux qui sont en
train de remonter donc quand vous devez
faire rouler deux mille milliards
d'euros de dette publique à taux zéro ou
à 1 ou 2 ou 3% ce n'est pas du tout la
même chose n'est pas du tout la même
chose hélas bruno le maire enfin pardon
villeroy de galhau le gouverneur de la
banque de pente vient de rappeler que 1
points une hausse de 1 % des taux
d'intérêt c'est l'équivalent de 39
milliards d'euros sur dix ans d'intérêt
supplémentaire payée par la payer par la
france
moi je voudrais quand même rappeler que
depuis
1974 la france a payé plus de 2000
milliards d'euros d'intérêts aux banques
privées donc ça pose la question quand
même du financement des états et
notamment du financement monétaire
et à quand christine lagarde avait dit
écoutez ça ne sert à rien d'annuler la
tête parce qu'aujourd'hui on l'a fait
rouler à taux zéro etc j'avais fait une
tribune dans marianne pour pour heures
pour lui répondre et lui demander à
écouter très bien nous on veut bien
abandonné l'idée est annulé la dette
publique mais dans ce cas là que la bce
s'engage à racheter l'ensemble des
dettes publiques sur les cinquante
prochaines années à taux zéro évidemment
la bce ne s'est pas engagé à ça donc
finalement fait rouler la dette
quand vous avez des achats de la bce à
taux zéro derrière ou comme vous n'en
avez pas et que cette dette vous devez
la placer sur les marchés avec des taux
d'intérêts potentiellement plus élevés
les conséquences pour les finances
publiques sont radicalement différentes
et c'est pour ça que l'annulation
conserve tout son intérêt maintenant
sûr je veux quand même dire un point
parce qu'il ya quelque chose sur
l'allemagne qui on ne serait pas
d'accord et c'est oui bien sûr sauf que
le grand problème c'est surtout que la
france l'italie et l'espagne ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux pour faire plier
l'allemagne ce qui pourrait faire s'il
était un peu plus coordonnée et un peu
plus unie et dire que l'annulation de la
tête la manne qui opposerait et alors
elle si vous poseraient certainement
mais il faut quand même pas oublier qu'à
la conférence de londres en 1953 les
deux tiers de la dette publique
allemande ont été effacés donc toute la
puissance économique allemande s'est
aussi bâti sur une annulation dette dont
elle a bénéficié et qu'aujourd'hui elle
refuse aux autres comme l a refusée aux
grecs en 2012 en design
impossible de restructurer la dette
publique grecque ce qui a plongé le pays
dans les difficultés qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui alors toute la faute n'est
évidemment pas sur l'allemagne mais
entend donc bien il ya un moment il faut
chercher des solutions pour en sortir et
je pense que avec une coordination des
autres pays européens l'italie notamment
qui est une des publics extrêmement
élevé qui peut se retrouver rapidement
en difficulté sur sa dette et bien des
actions sont possibles il faut un peu
d'imagination un peu de volonté
politique pour sortir de la situation
dans laquelle on est qui par ailleurs
nous nous paralyse complètement ils nous
empêchent de financer la reconstruction
écologique et sociale dont nous avons
besoin alors justement religieux je
voudrais vous faire réagir attendait
parce que multiplication des erreurs
tout ma main le le coup de on ne peut
pas parce que les taux sont en train de
remonter donc ça va nous coûter cher
rassurez-vous à la bce ne va pas arrêter
son son quantitative easing ne va pas
arrêter sa politique des taux zéro même
si dans la communication elle le fait
souvenez-vous de pauwels enfin 2018
c'était exactement la même chose il
avait considéré à ce moment là que
l'économie américaine repartait
tellement fort qu'il pouvait se
permettre d'avoir des taux à trois et
demi les marchés ont plongé les banques
centrales aujourd'hui son market
dépendantes ehpad date indépendante et
donc qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait elles
ont recommencé leur politique de taux
zéro aujourd'hui on a une telle dette à
rouler on a une telle d'être à émettre
parce qu'on va avoir un déficit
budgétaire encore abyssal en 2022 et
donc le les dettes qui arrivent à
échéance il va falloir les rouler aussi
et donc croyez moi ont les taux les taux
d'intérêt vont vite rebaisser parce que
les taux d'intérêts aujourd'hui ne sont
pas fixés par le marché mais bien fixé
par la banque centrale qui n'arrêtent
pas d'acheter et quand elles n'arrêtent
pas d'acheter elle fait baisser les taux
donc sauf sait pas on remonte
aujourd'hui oui les taux remontent
aujourd'hui ponctuellement ils
redescendront derrière donc c'est pas un
sujet aujourd'hui sur le sur les taux
d'intérêt quand j'ai dit ça en 2018 tout
le monde s'est foutu de ma gueule ça
n'empêche que j'avais raison d'aidés
2010 dès le début 2010 donc c'est un
faux problème et la deuxième chose sûre
sur le set sur cette dette
expliquez moi un truc franchement
vous venez de trouver en fait le le
mouvement perpétuel
c'est génial on aimait de la dette et
puis un petit coup de tipp-ex la bce la
rachète un petit coup de tipp-ex et elle
l'est face c'est formidable en fait vous
venez de découvrir quelque chose de
fabuleux mais à ce moment là cher
monsieur pourquoi appelle-t-on des
impôts pourquoi appelle-t-on des impôts
moi je veut plus payer d'impôts si c'est
si facile
moi je considère à ce moment là que la
bce ne devrait pas s'arrêter à 25 %
pourquoi elles n'achètent pas finalement
toute la dette d'accor alors je vais
vous donner une chose à faire demain
vous filer quatre mille balles à tous
les français d'accord quatre mille
balles appelle les secrétaires monnaie
ça vous coûte ça vous coûte 268
milliards
la bce rachète ses 268 elle les efface
et donc c'est très bien tout le monde
est plus riche de quatre mille balles un
même le bébé qui vient de naître se
prend quatre mille balles dans son
berceau pourquoi pas si c'est si simple
si cécilia aucune conséquence et bien ne
payons plus d'impôts faisons ça avec la
bce qui va émettre chaque année pour
tous les pays
de quoi payer les gens à rien
d'accord parce que c'est quand même ça
le rêve un alors évidemment tout le
monde va être content avec votre
proposition parce que c'est quand même
assez génial de pouvoir être payés et de
vivre dans le dans le métavers ce on ne
foutent rien de toute la journée c'est
génial sauf que sauf que ya une
conséquence est que ça vous oublier
malheureusement l influence de la donner
nicolas dufresne des réactions jeu
je pense anticipé la conséquence auquel
pense monsieur de la maj qui veulent
anticiper pas puisque vous donner cette
méthode pour pour tab à 6 justement je
vais vous répondre donc en fait que de
ce que vous dites là bon c'est quelque
chose de bien connus et depuis longtemps
c'est milton friedman qui disait vous
savez la création monétaire c'est un peu
comme une soirée alcoolisée au début
tout le monde se fait plaisir vous
envoyer le champagne et puis le
lendemain vous avez la gueule de bois
etc l'inflation bon voilà donc ça c'est
ce qu'on dit depuis les années 70 sur la
création monétaire bon notre mon point
de vue le point de vue de l'institut
rousseau d'un certain nombre d'économies
c'est complètement différent c'est que
effectivement aujourd'hui nous aurions
besoin de créer de la monnaie et je vais
même vous vous vous choqué davantage que
que ce que vous avez
anticiper c'est à dire qu'on promet mme
la création monétaire libre c'est-à-dire
sans dette associée c'est à dire qu'on
pense qu' il faudrait à un moment que
imaginé un système démocratique qui
permettrait de dire à la banque centrale
de financer sans dette associée puisque
le grand problème de la monnaie
aujourd'hui c'est que toute création
monétaire est associé à une dette et
donc à un moment il faut rend il faut
rompre ce cercle vicieux et pouvoir
avoir une partie de la monnaie une
petite partie de la monnaie bien
évidemment qu'ils soient créées sans
dettes pour financer des objectifs
économiques et sociaux et notamment la
reconstruction écologique c'est une
proposition qui avait été faite
notamment on l'a oublié dans l'est au
début des années 80 y compris par des
économistes et des députés de droite à
l'époque qui disaient qu'il fallait il
fallait créer une troisième section dans
la loi de finances pour avoir une
création
monétaire libre et donc financer des
dépenses des dépenses d'intérêt général
alors évidemment le problème de
l'inflation alors moi je ne suis pas
pour l'hélicoptère monnaie comme vous
avez dit qui consisterait à distribuer
4000 euros à tout le monde pourquoi je
suis pas pour les hélicoptères ne l'est
pas ce que l'hélicoptère monnaie elle
conduit à reproduire les formes de
l'activité économique et non pas à les
transformer or ce qu'il faut faire avec
la création monétaire s'est transformée
l'activité économique et notamment
verdir l'économie c'est pour ça qu'il
faudrait créer une partie de monnaie qui
viennent financer des investissements
écologiques qui ne sont aujourd'hui pas
financé parce qu'ils ne sont pas assez
rentables ou parce qu'ils sont rentables
à trop long terme et tout ça créerait de
l'emploi créerait de l'activité et crée
de la compétitivité pour notre pays
parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut bien
comprendre que c'est l'insee qui le dit
il faudrait 60 milliards d'euros
d'investissements en plus chaque année
pour financer ce dont on a besoin en
matière de transition écologique ces 60
milliards d'euros on est on les trouve
pas et donc je termine par là la
création monétaire vous savez est ce que
vous dites là c'est finalement très
aligné avec ce que dit la banque
centrale européenne vous allez dans les
murs de la banque centrale européenne à
francfort il y à une fresque la fresque
du faust de goethe qui décrit une scène
où le diable méphistophélès vient
conseiller l'empereur du saint-empire
romain pour créer de la monnaie et lui
dire attention surtout ne ne crée pas de
la monnaie pour le peuple parce que
l'inflation c'est le diable et et voilà
donc cesser cette position et c'est
cette position que nous contestons que
je conteste je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
création monétaire peut être un outil
majeur pour le développement économique
merci merci beaucoup à nicolas dufresne
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous directeur
de l'institut rousseau
merci merci olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivie
pour voir ou revoir nos précédents
numéros rendez vous sur notre site
internet à l'adresse rt france point tv
et n'oubliez pas de réagir à cette
émission sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rt4 cash en skate avec à votre
mot de la fin olivier et bien écoutez
j'ai peur qu'à force de vouloir verdir
tous ont jauni ce